[Music]
hey what's going on YouTube
oh [ __ ] I'm in my room this here is a
little bit of or what was some [ __ ]
vodka club soda ah now it has been
recently brought to my attention because
I haven't been vlogging too much and a
lot of you guys have been complaining
about that because there really isn't
too much content on my channel anymore
well mother [ __ ] I'm just praying you
guys brought up this thing about this
girl [ __ ] her name is the gabbie show
and this dude named rice rice bum now
rice bum that doesn't sound right uh did
I do any research on the [ __ ] right gum
I'm so sorry I wasn't me trying to be
offensive to the dude I just ah
apparently a few of you out there said
that just do the rice scum Asian guy
your glasses of [ __ ] slap the [ __ ] okay
now for me as a content creator I'm not
here to add [ __ ] to the flames and
personally I don't know what the [ __ ]
went down I didn't do too much research
on this and mainly wise because on this
subject matter I don't give up look it's
not that I don't give a [ __ ] that women
get hit out there I just don't give a
[ __ ] about two youtubers dramas you got
to realize something about this man when
a youtuber decides to put out
information about another youtuber
saying that they struck them or whatever
you got to realize that it's for you
because they're trying to do this for
entertainment purposes do I believe that
he hit her or not I don't [ __ ] know
but if you guys do want to get the
lowdown on things and what other people
have been saying generally from like the
tendinous research that i did the girl
Gabby was you know fooling around like
most young youtubers do you know with
the whole snapchat in the video thing
and as she was doing it the dude didn't
want her duty as I go get that [ __ ] out
of my face and it got to the point where
it got so annoying for him he grabbed
her phone and smash it to pieces
that's some [ __ ] crazy-ass [ __ ]
because no matter how mad I get as
somebody else depending on who they
aren't especially if they're an
influencer and they're just really doing
it to have fun I'm not going to grab
their phone and smash it number one if
you're a person that could grab a phone
from a [ __ ] and smash it on the floor
clearly you've got a lot of money now I
look at this dude's channel he gets like
millions of views for on his [ __ ]
[ __ ] then dude can I have a job running
low imma drink
other sources meeting rice rice jumpin
ah [ __ ] coma himself said that he got
irritated because once again with a hole
no don't film me grab her folks smash to
pieces watch the [ __ ] on out
I said hey my bad and he like bed mode
her like two G's in apologies first of
all I'm pretty sure that foam wasn't
worth to geez and you know what can you
smash my phone and give me $2,000 what
the foot how ballin are these young
youtubers man like they make so much
[ __ ] money I'm over here listen let
me say something when I walk into a
restaurant I still look at the number on
the side and see which one what about
getting you know how mad Muriel gets to
me when I look at her and I tell me can
we split a steak like this is the crazy
[ __ ] to me know people like to air out
all their [ __ ] laundry and the people
that I guess in general who get the most
entertainment out of it is you so if
you're out there getting riled up about
the [ __ ] number one think about it like
this do you honestly think that these
two people are really that
confrontational do you honestly think
that these two people have actual real
[ __ ] problems none of us really do
you have to realize that we as youtubers
who do make a living out of creating
content we have first world problems and
that's coming from me yeah a lot of our
problems are real problems but they're
[ __ ] first of all problems the [ __ ]
[ __ ] had her phone in his face which
it wasn't right for him to grab and
smash her [ __ ] boat wasn't really
that big of a [ __ ] deal
but maybe when somebody says respect
their space you probably should do it
but that's the kind of world that you
guys live in right you live in this
world where you just got a film [ __ ]
everything and according to most people
it seems like he didn't really hit her I
mean that's he said she said type of
thing if she said that he did maybe he
did I don't [ __ ] know what I mean by
firstworldproblems is that this is just
some [ __ ] YouTube quote-unquote
celebrity drama that could have been
solved without publicizing it out to the
whole world but they did because why it
gets [ __ ] views do you think that
publicise half the [ __ ] and the drama
that I have with
people that may or may not be on this
space there's a lot of youtubers out
that I could give two [ __ ] shits
about and that's really what it is and
it's okay for me to not like a few
people by the way some people get
freaked out when they hear oh my god you
all like this youtuber why cuz I don't
wanna [ __ ] it life and that's why not
everybody likes everybody [ __ ] but on
that account I am very very respectful
to the people that I dislike just
because I dislike you doesn't mean I'm
gonna walk up to you and let me stick my
dick in your face which I have not done
yet oh we're not I'm a drink but once
again if you have friends out there
right now that are riled up about this
situation about a guy getting into an
altercation with another person and
breaking their phone
it's really that big of a [ __ ] deal
it isn't right I'm pretty sure you have
bigger problems out to live there are
people out there who can't pay the bills
who got kids who got a lot of bad [ __ ]
happening to them to rich people
arguing about somebody snapchatting
somebody else and breaking their phone
and giving them $2,000 for it it's not a
[ __ ] big deal for anybody to make up
oh my god like I said before if somebody
broke my phone and gave me $2,000 that
is the happiest day of my life not only
do I get a brand-new phone and an iPhone
7 plus which is about 700 800 bucks
anyways I on top of that have an extra
like [ __ ] $1,300 to play around with
that means I could get that state for
burial and not have to split it I should
have done what they were doing I should
have walked around is collecting videos
talking [ __ ] about children and the
other one that did vine I should have
done that [ __ ] but I couldn't because I
was so stuck trying to be in movies or
[ __ ] and create a movie tupid I know
what you're thinking - Oh David you
Drive a Tesla you're rich I got that
Tesla and I regret it every day but if I
can't even get grocery this [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] did I do I never buy anything nice
my boxers have been around for [ __ ]
15 years and I haven't bought new ones
this shirt I got at Target for a [ __ ]
role to play a nerd geek Asian in a
[ __ ] sitcom that I didn't get and it
feels great so I'm still wearing it yeah
[ __ ] ball is life
I gotta go eat another pocket of wrong
[Music]
pick the
[Music]